[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères mes chers collègues c'est par
un décret en catimini au coeur de l'été
2018 le 3 août précisément que le poison
a commencé lentement à se répandre ce
poison c'est celui de la république des
copains qui permet un romancier
contemplateur du couple présidentiel de
nommer philippe besson consul général à
los angeles au lieu d'une personne dont
c'est tout simplement le métier de
représenter la france et nos
compatriotes à l'étranger ce poison
madame la ministre n'a depuis eu de
cesse de miner notre diplomatie qui
pâtit d'une absence de vision de
consultation et de concertation
depuis le début de l'année je me suis
rendu dans près de 30 pays soit autant
de rencontres avec nos postes
diplomatiques
partout la même inquiétude monte oui
l'inquiétude monte ça ça une réforme à
la fois injuste et incompréhensible
vous avez pris la décision de supprimer
le corps diplomatique
après cinq ans d'une politique
d'improvisation constante vous avez
décidé qu'il était désormais possible de
s'improviser aussi diplomate
or ne s'improvise pas diplomate c'est
une vocation une carrière que l'on
construit au fil des expériences oui
l'inquiétude monte face au manque de
considération pour nos diplomates dont
plusieurs dizaines attendent encore
aujourd'hui leur affectation pour la
rentrée lorsque vous agissez ainsi c'est
l'image de la france qui est abîmée et
la voix de la france qui est affaibli
oui la france peut se targuer de
bénéficier d'un solide réseau qui a su
s'ouvrir largement et se diversifier
depuis plusieurs années oui la france
est riche de ce corps diplomatique de
son savoir faire et de son expertise
respecté partout dans le monde et si ce
corps doit évoluer selon moi cela doit
se faire dans l'écouté le respect et la
concertation sans esprit partisan et
certainement pas avec un décret pris
discrètement entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle
madame la ministre avez vous conscience
de l'image désastreuse que cette réforme
injuste renvoi en france comme à
l'étranger
que comptez vous faire pour permettre à
notre diplomatie de poursuivre sa
mission de manière professionnelle
et sereine